all right so we're just gonna pick up from where the interrogation ended so
Langness at this point is going to bring the Denden Mushi that was ringing
below deck up on the top deck where so was everyone listening on the Denden
Mushi at the top deck because a kid would not be kid would be navigating the
well not navigating you know just yeah just making sure that it was on top deck
yeah yeah then yeah this is the new one here
mouth is where you listening in okay at this point I'll say Linus will walk up
and he will show you the Denden Mushi ringing map taste
okay I got to turn the music down a bit
shift space
all right on the other side of the Denden Mushi it's just gonna be silence for a
while and then the person on the other side with their like kind of like a
changed or altered voice is coming through it so it's not their actual voice
they will just you also hear like tapping on the desk like he's maybe like
tapping his fingers on the desk making like noise like that and the only
thing he says in the beginning is where is he
I can tell this is one of the Denden Mushis that yeah it is the
world than in mushy yeah I suppose you think not talking to me would get you
anonymity but you made a mistake taking that vehicle now I have only one thing to
say to you pirate and we're over dropping a mouth to a safe location and I will
call off the worship sams ending after you
well you're saying something or just saying quiet the whole time
okay the vehicle would be somewhere around here at the top deck you can make
intelligence check investigations that will take a while and the meantime I
just gonna stay silent I don't find anything you honestly don't believe after all he's done that I'm just gonna be able to work with that using the good you.
what I it written I didn't ask for your thoughts on the matter as soon as he says
that you hear someone walk in to his room in the background as he like kind of
shouts out to him Commodore break we have arrived on the Sibala Kingdom the new
king the kingdom is waiting in the other room what should we say and the guy on the
call goes brings a man in I fear the king might be getting aggressive with the
Commodore and would have to be put in his place tell him to wait for me a little bit
more I'll be there so do you understand your position now pirate
Linus at this point will join out like some sort of like mechanical device attached to one of the
wheels of the vehicle as he owns it a joint set out he shows it to you and chucks it in the ocean
you know nothing about you call me a creature call me a pirates but I know I know it all
and I know if you got four oh is mine and unfortunately there's nothing you can do
that is going to jump that until I make him so go ahead call me whatever name you may please
but you're not getting what you want from me
such uncivility this is why would it what I would expect from being from the lower realm
very well I'll collect his corpse if I have to ask for your friend
might be joining you in the afterlife as well it was good to talk to you
now I'm sure we'll be meeting soon enough he clicks it as the Denon Mushi goes silent
Linus kinds of walks up to you he goes you sure you meant the right choice
there's not much to do
if anything the millions will just take advantage of the fact that we can't get back to the
destabella they probably still rampage the place and then take borrower even if we did jump him up
when we left the top of them we let them know that the choice was theirs to make
one more their future we are not the rest all I can do is hope
would not be so sure I know that man and he has not one to bluff
I will honor your decision but it seems like we're already too late he points towards
like the right side as you see like big galleons of warship kind of coming close towards towards you
from where you were from the side of newsold and lexin period so the warships that were gathered there
are coming towards you as they followed the signal from Vorosweko all right let's get into your first
naval battle let's go everyone in combat and
our ship did take damage a while ago right yes yes it did
oh boy it is on 560 HP out of 600 not 600
I will be in motion
so you have one swivel gun where do you want it to be
wish or action once swivel gun do you want to someone else to roll for you
yeah let me give you his sheet success
leaning you the fold my teeth configure ownership uh milphous owner there we go you should have access now
there we go line is there we go loop there we go my balls
and nice servitude tiger sim i'm gonna remove dravos from the thing because he's still unconscious
remove participant and zim is a well all she's been she will be awake but she won't be helping
in the fight because she's very much nodded in a great conditioned fight uh the rest are in combat and
let me uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh in pc ships there we go
oh it's just a small ship it's fine i didn't skill it up
all right uh it's multiple by the way it's not just the one
oh it's multiple of those small ones
all right let's get ready to fight
first of the horses for start of the horses because they're gonna go
crazy as they hear the first
fire from first wallies of cannon fire uh there we go
oh sorry um me
um
media tech one two three four
uh okay so it was on at 20 19 five
what's your ships AC
oh god i need to keep it token for your ship as well i guess there we go
i see now the in comparison it looks small
oh it's not the small ship
uh what's the AC man 15 okay all will head except for one i think eight twenty two no two
wanted two will head let me damage normal and then normal damage pull us
just double the normal damage right that was our rules for the crit
okay so eight no where the fuck is the crit one okay so it's 17 and then a crit would be
30 47 okay 47 plus another 17
and then divided by two that's what your ship will take
uh so that's 32 okay
five sixty minus thirty two
by 28 okay as the first wallie comes in the horses will kind of go wild as
they will break off from like the below deck you can hear like the noises as they will break
off and try to get up on the deck there we go it's their turn
yes
it's the music not going what the fuck is it um combat there we go
all right next is minus
okay uh
he will no listen
uh okay he will go toward the hell and maybe try to get you guys out of here
all right
next is mouth is what's the plan i don't know ask
that's the plan
all right bird
what form is this the new bird
did he not i don't think he's seen yeah he's he's never seen you the second forum
yeah i've only seen zapdos
hmm is this zapdos evolution
i keep forgetting like none of you have like actually
been in combat with each other for a long time except for baptismalphys
call lightning where are you placing the lightning because you you have a range the ship is very far
where right now
300 uh let me check the range
on the cannon yeah the cannon is like 500 feet so it would it would be very far
it's 120 okay okay what are just transforming that's it
okay okay to no transforming what what are we doing
tuning that cannon then i guess you don't have a cannon you have a swivel gun that's about it
yeah yeah that one there all right
yeah yeah i'll say at the top of the yeah the swivel gun also has a range so you can you can
let me check what's the range on the swivel gun can you see the ships token
here here in the in the water
oh you're just small one yeah yeah just just double click and then swivel gun should be inside
it also has like 450 range so you should be able to hit him
that's 480 feet what the fuck that is crazy
yeah that will that add your proficiency bonus if you have a
i mean if what you're not okay yeah yeah 11
okay i don't think so unless you're proficient you don't have anything
then that's it just 11 11 okay all right you have your electric power still
no i don't think so he used all of it in the last one on one well no they got deleted
no no i mean for the flavor i used all of the dust right yeah
the saber truth will not do anything we just try to not panic i guess uh it's cage turn he will
hand over the helm to linus as he runs up to you map teased captain what are the orders
okay i'll try to calm them calm them out he will try to calm them down
to today there we go
when i 20 days they are calm as he takes them downstairs again
they just fall asleep no no again this
picking them downstairs as his whole turn all right it's your turn map teased
obviously can't fight back right now
is the ship considered a creature no
it's not i don't think it's a creature
and why would a ship be a creature it's an object sure won't be a creature
okay i'm not objectifying anything if it's an object it is an object i'm not changing
its status from not an object to an object
all right what's the plan what he was the plan
i don't know he's still my god
you
should have gotten that upgrade huh
we did not have time no i think i think you had time for the flight one yeah
i think so i'll check anyway come come up with the plan now then
because it was evening when we let word with the morning after uh dude was ready to leave
okay okay
they're out of the 120 feet range so i can't even do that what it is 60 days no it might
yeah we had two most like you know we had one
you said they're how far away um out five hundred or something
feet away they're catching up soon what are we expected to do to this like
is our ship already moving yeah yeah you're moving this way you're moving this way they're coming
this way line is is moving the ship towards yeah minus is already doing that he's moving here
i'm just going to shoot this move okay so he's just gonna push me else this away
grab the gun to do yeah okay shoot it
i pressed it but it's not problem
doesn't have
all right next just roll up
uh i mean i think the action economy yeah yeah sure why not
yeah
now for us also an extra attack yeah yeah you can roll you can roll the extra attack to
me i think there's like stuff with reroll let me check swivel gun yes swivel gun just takes
a bonus action to reload so it should be fine you should be able to attack twice uh 13
whiffs three whiffs so essentially you like all your uh like ammo is right now currently
just hitting the side of the warships that that are following you
shouldn't there be some bonus to do gun at least like or decks or some disarray technique again you
don't have ranged it says here that for anything you have to have proficiency to add and you have
to your mortifiers let me check again and in the dn dnd uh thing and not gun ranged ranged
wait wait you guys are chip
just bald men uh where the fuck is canon god damn it
we need syracal yeah can there we go uh it is when you are fired up as you make a range attack with
the role when using your dick sturdy modifier okay never mind it is for us
unless you have proficiency with cannons you do not add your okay unless you have proficiency
with cannons you do not add your proficiency modifier to the attack okay so you definitely add
your decks okay uh 13 and what else yeah 13 and 18
no 18 will be yeah but the other two still left right yeah okay 13 becomes 18 let me check
yeah that 18 would hit roll damage for the 13 you see it kind of like
bumps into the outer armor of the ship and just like it embeds into the front armor of the ship
and that's it all right next is rumour rumour
so i'm gonna walk out yeah you just hear like cannon fire all over the ship
yeah and i'm gonna walk out and be like what the fuck have you got nested into
and i'm gonna be like where how far are they out
rumour can you can you make a perception for me with advantage
yeah roe like i don't see no ships
yeah you you see them you see them they're very far away
Jesus Christ
what the fuck are we doing boss
lioness can you can you dash that far i fear it will not be that easy my friend
the ship is in bad condition and those worships definitely have far more capabilities to catch up
pretty quickly so they don't sink us with borough on the ship well i might have something
let me find that what's what's the young boy's name
what young boy it's a chuprite or the ham's man
cave okay okay boss you were mouth is you start throwing the missiles back at them
and then i'll stay in here and i'll give you guys some refreshments
because you guys are gonna get tired until they get closer and you could have Bob just
man the missile i mean the more people on the missiles are better right
one muscle you know what you guys are better at like doing the deflect yes yes that's a very good idea
i'm just saying and then out you guys get tired i'll give you something to pop you up till they
get closer and then we can use lioness to get on the ship room how much is your dicks 14
no i can talk that okay i'll be on the missile that's what i figured i'll just be over here cooking
all right you know just to make it make sense i'll say you have multiple swivel guns
but only one of them can man them one at one time so you know it doesn't mess up with the
i don't i don't understand how everyone just crowd on one single swivel guns so
we're pushing each other away okay it's my first
all right during this whole excite everyone's lighting over the swivel
in his butt pieces are going to go yeah it's loose turn and it's going to use all of this movement
to run below the heck and then dash
and somewhere near arcade or something you got the horses wrangled up right yeah yeah
eat tied down the horses all right bobs your turn
bobs mm-hmm
right so yeah it's my turn um it is your turn let me see let's
I see no no no it's my turn to play with the with the toys okay um if i am not mistaken uh i can
come over here and push them out the way and uh it is dex right yes
and i would love to thank you for giving me the thing just before today's session
because yeah one of the thing it does is yeah you can move stats around
what are you what are you decreasing first you that's the i have i have no need of sprints right now so
okay so remove whatever from sprints but you can only go to 20 by the way
yeah yeah yeah i uh yeah 28 uh let me let me let me uh i am very slow with technology
so just a minute
what armor are you wearing bomb uh what are you wearing i am wearing splint armor i think uh well
i think for splint you as heavy i need a decent 13th rank wear it yeah yeah he has he has enough
strength you you don't need to move it to eight you need to just take it down to three you can only
get max 20 decks you don't that right yeah okay you need a 15 you need a 15 to wear a splint
oh good thing okay i'll just take it from cons uh i'll take it from cons and okay that all right
take it from your wisdom hello i know i can't do that so and i just wrote what do i roll
why are your stats fucked up with 16 15 a why is it 15 you only
no i increase my decks remember yeah but it says 15 on your
my car was 14 oh okay yeah my car was 14 what let me let me check yeah but your dex is only 15
is it fine it was nine before and it's okay and then it's fine okay yeah go ahead roll
i hope you find the swivel gun and i click on it and i ready the standard roll attack
just do the other thing please and you know nice you can use the extra attack i would love to actually
uh 17 does it does it it's not actually hit
okay another thing uh can i call uh since i can telemetically communicate with my horse uh if
it's within one mile can i call out my horse and uh do the same thing like full cover to uh Kate
okay where do you want to cover at
like i want to cover Kate because if he is not there we can't move our ship so
now Kate is below deck line is the one right now navigating
oh okay then he doesn't need it never mind yeah
but can i can the car horse come out on the ship if in case we
is it a bonus action is it a normal action no it's just you just call the horse to leave
no action okay it should be something let me show my mount casting time 10 minute
no uh it's like the horse all this days remember i said i casted it long time ago so
oh oh so like it the initial initial thing yeah okay i'll say you use a bonus action you still have
to call the horse like it's non-magic revenge yeah so i just call it and yeah yeah
all right next is the horses and i'm gonna remove this one and just keep the the horse only moves
on your turn right horse doesn't have his own what do you mean?
yeah so it's the same turn right yeah so i'm just gonna get rid of these guys from the
remove all right uh line this will phase down to below deck he will grab Kate and he will ask him to
go up or just send him up and boost him up or something and he runs into his room the room that he
put his stuff in and he grabs something all right mouth is oh sorry about this time the other
walley will start coming in and they're pretty close at this point they're probably around like
100 to 100 meters range let me start with the walley tech normal
edges excuse tech
and uh you see at the center or like in front at the center there's this like huge cannon
has it locks down and it's just going to shoot your ship right in the mid lane
oh is it the wrong one? do you use christ wrong one?
anyway it it rolled sevens anyway so that means is one two three three of them head one two
three yeah you can do that
so I have anything that's gonna help
routine uh 10 and 14 17
and 16 okay the 16 which ones are you deflecting the 14 one and the 10 one right
because you can only target one thing to reflect you can't reflect multiple bullets
right yeah there's one is 10 yeah there's one 10 once 14 16 and 10 so 16 and 14 you're
deflecting the 10 you take it okay well yeah all right let me update the hp
did you do there we go
uh the other ship you start to see is coming from behind and it's trying to uh maybe box you in
so it's it's taking like the long route and it's going to turn around and come towards you
from the other side
all right mouth is
I think it's your turn right yeah can I add this to the combat I can let's go
um you know what all the reroll just okay so okay it rolled 21 okay it should
needs to go to there we go you know
oh that's misses yeah definitely misses you should have straight up in the air
everyone's like snatching it away from each other
all right and think else you want to try because it's now in range
what you did use both your
all right next is
okay uh the saber tiger it's going to struggle that said
can is up here and he will start to move the ship let me see
now we get there we go
all right the hell seems to be stuck
maybe some damage to the rudder or something like that
sister in taste the swelgon gun is free right now
you just sit there how far uh they're probably like around this range
basically they're like uh nose of the ship is here and there goes the whole ship here
they can't board just yet but they will be able to next turn whoever's on the ship
I mean to the people who are on the cannons won't leave the cans
there's not how never warfare works some board the ship some try to sink the ship yeah
hello to flag kick on a board doll you can board them
i'm not just giving you a leg up
I read to the other side already
I will be to use um barb as like a wall to launch myself
all right go back to the other ship
all right can you make an acrobatics
this will go very badly indeed
um
why don't you stick the landing uh as you jump across the water you see like the waves kind of
uh splitting as this warship kind of makes it swayed through the waves uh you jump onto the
ball of the ship and you see a bunch of maris just grab their um pistols and readying themselves
to get into the fight let me see
uh that is no that's movement right so that's just movement just counts in the movement but it's a jump
so it will like cut uh it's bonus right jumping is bonus i'm pretty sure
it says it's not a bonus it is parts of character's movement character movement speed so it's not
bonus all right uh so how much feet vertically would it would it have been 30 feet or something
i'll say so yeah it's fine it's just going to use movement speed i'll say you use all your
movement speed getting on the ship because it's not easy to get on the ship with just jumping right
you know all right you have two actions and your bonuses well the the top of the ship you
you see the big giant cannon in the middle that just vizpaz and essentially just splash some water
on you but around the cannon you see three people manning that cannon and you see on the side of
the ship there's four cannons at the top four cannons below deck but only four cannons are facing
toward you so that those four are firing right now uh and every every cannon has three people man
and there are other Marines on the ship that are now pointing the guns at you the rest are still
focusing on your ship the main cannon no the main cannon missed the 64 pound cannon missed last turn
you know what i'm actually just going to take the dodge actually all right uh let me know this guys
in the initiative all right the guards will go just after you were okay
he's Jesus all right uh you see four guards kind of come not guards uh the
the four of the Marines come towards you uh but they are still being cautious because you
were reported to be spotted at the church and you did take down a bunch of Marines there
and they're gonna just shoot from afar one two three three four five six
all right uh 19 damage all of these are with with the submanage as well
yeah he dodging oh he is dodging yeah yeah yeah well one of them hit so i'll just i'm just gonna roll
for that one either with the dodge i'm gonna roll again to check if it misses or not
can't you deflect it i can't
i'm gonna add 20 so 19 would hit uh and it's gonna be five do you want to deflect it
i mean you can right all right yeah yeah all right we just take five damage for no reason
all right do you want to deflect or just you know ping just a factor okay uh as all of these
volleys of bullets just shoot you it just all of them again goes straight through you uh and yeah
that's it the last one kind of uh went through your eye but it still did not hit
uh all right next is Roma and you said they're a hundred feet away correct
they're a hundred the fit the ship itself is a hundred feet away but you can jump onto the
like this nose of the ship essentially but it's still facing this way
i don't think my fat ass is gonna be able to jump no
fuck
baby your spirit what debut the spirit yeah debut the spirit you can do that
yeah yeah um shit i'm smoking it right now like yeah
uh all right air air elemental
yep air elemental and just fucking see what i can do with it
all right there we go okay what do you want this air elemental to look like
um there's kind of a picture of it already in the uh no no no just flavor rice what do you
want it to look like all right we're as such as of course uh of course of course uh let me see if
I can give you the permission for this one Roma owner there you go you can control it now
all right as you see like this uh image uh forming out of like the smoke and steam in your kitchen
you see like a big like burly uh woman like forming in front of you with like a sous chef hat
as uh it's just like a smacks boat of his uh it's fest and it's just ready to rumble
and i'm gonna be like all right let's go out here i'm gonna kick the doors open another kitchen
you know you know all the afterglite and be like all right let's fucking do this
so the front of the ship is like towards the front of our ship right
so i'm gonna what it can fly 90 feet
yeah but i'm sure what is whirlwind like is that the whirlwind is each creature in the elemental space
must make a DC check if a strong target strikes an object such as a ball let me check is it a placed
thing that's what i was trying to know no it has to be the center of it
oh my dude has to be in the center of it yeah yeah yeah and i can fly 90 feet
yeah how far how so how far is the tip of the ship like where Baptiste's dudes are
in my air amount uh i'm just going uh it can move that far
okay i'm gonna i'll say because it's flying so there's no like interruption in the movement so
i'll say it can get that far so i'm gonna place it right in the middle of those four dudes and i'm
gonna use whirlwind okay uh roll okay i just have to roll DC 13
all of them will fail rule damage okay what is the damage on this there is object damage
that's what i was gonna do that that's the goal is the it's he just that's all that let me do was
that no no no uh click on uh open the sheet there is an object damage on it
open whirlwind and then click object damage
it's not let me click object oh i gotta click the fucking thing yeah you can scale the spell essentially
all right ten all of them will take ten damage and what's the is there is there a throw or something
i remember yeah i thought they got the wrong uh twenty feet away from the elemental in random
direction and knocked prone okay so i'm for some rolls uh roll one the two four five people so
i'm gonna six people sorry cc two we have rolls two dies all of them roll two oh my god okay four
of them roll two one of them rolls one uh so two of them just collapse towards like the side of
the ship as the other four just get fling off the ship as they are now in the in the water um
all right the thing that's your turn yeah
so one action is summoning one action is making it do the thing
and so uh all right blue is just going to wait there and that's it Bob
it is he is he's he's under the deck
Bobby boy what are you doing
oh Bob did you not hear he's not here nice he's probably just gonna use the can in a couple more
times yeah all right uh i won't roll for him so i'll give someone else the next step
don't give it give it to mouth this yeah i'm gonna give it to mouth this uh configure ownership
Bob owner okay mouth this so there you go i should give all of you
did Bob say anything before leaving no no no
Bob has told the dead guidance is it is it the right Bob why is he still have all of these bombs
yeah yeah yeah
that is the bomb in the dead yeah i think he gets gantryps
not exactly sure what his
flavor for it is now it's a pistol gun it's pistol gun right in his
like a finger gun he points at somebody's like you don't pop up
i think he he still has his old arm he just pulls it out
this Bob sees someone that shoot at the cannon to say to you want to shoot at the cannon
no wait i'm gonna see moment
guys ladies
and feeble meant a black wing of uh and a reading energy from your finger towards the
creature within range make the range spell okay it started at the creature though
yeah there's someone that's shooting and they do his day yeah okay
do i need to make something no i need to hit
hey i hit 25 that's nice uh okay what's the damage target needs only half damage with a weapon
tag that used the chosen ability modifier in the creature ends
okay what what what modify are you choosing next like an
all right uh and at the end of each of the creatures turning can make you concede to
cheats no go right that's Bob okay that's Bob next is
the warship and it's going to get ready for another walley one two
three and four
let's see who's main in the guns 14 the Marines are still many the guns the Marines that were on the
boat the ones that Baptist was fighting that's what the Marines you target right
yeah yeah i'm just over fighting different Marines okay
tt tt tt tt tt tt
all right
new four 26 and 10 some guessing 26 gets halfed and the rest hit fine so yeah now we can do a con save
i guess to save 24 26
fly as half damage and then 10 doesn't yeah it does hit right okay yeah
yeah it takes one action so three there's three people on each cannon so one guy this job is just two
so it's using three actions every time yeah
i think that's the that's it for the cannon for the big cannon it's in the books so i'm going to
tell you it takes three three whole actions for all the three Marines that are there to reload
clean and everything and then shoot so it's so now it's the second turn it's going to fire after
the next turn all right slain is his turn he gets back up and he will go to the edge the back
end of the ship as he starts to pour something in the water all right next is
now it's time
all right are you focusing this on
the ship that was closing in or the ship that's close
no the thing closing in closing it's pretty far away
yeah the the other ship that's circling around is pretty far away
that will let me check where are you placing it because that will take out how how watch what's the
total like the range of the sphere
this well it's a range of 120 where it's 60 feet south of there why it's not 60 feet this is not 60 feet
what is happening 60 feet radius
right let me check
yeah yeah so that's fine that's that's fine then
so essentially you call lightning on the whole ship and what what what are the effects
so I have to make Dexay for everyone yeah I need to choose like
how many creatures choose a point where you can see under the cloud lighting boat shoots
from the cloud to that point each creature within the five feet okay makes Dexay so which can
and are you focusing on are you focusing on the other two Marines that are still on on the ship
fighting let's get that big cannon out of the way okay uh Dexay for all three Marines
I'm gonna just roll once and if they fail they all fail was it Dexay for
I made an ability but this doesn't matter okay three you 10 lightning please
yeah do the damage
just roll 3d 10 normally what he's not gonna have the same fruit
oh that's 10 that takes out the three Marines temporarily but they get back up
oh that's 20 oh it was look oh because you're you're targeting yeah no man
you're targeted that's why I looked at 20 because you have half I think resistance or something
all right so that's gonna be 20 each one of them just gets struck like the the lightning
struck strikes in like between the cannon and the cannon alongside with these three just explode
in the center of it and that's gonna be
how far away would you be from the cannon I'm gonna just roll the damage for force
roll 15 the 10
90 holy shit are you dead baptism I mean I just hopped on the ship so I don't know how far
because that's a big cannon I uh let me see the explosion radius
I am dodging that's 20 20 feet yeah I don't know
well can you at least make it that safe to like yeah yeah this is just that safe
can I get that damage since I was dodging
you want to take the full damage
what would you say if we can get it bad news oh yeah yeah sure
go but these made that next day yeah you're good yeah you're good you're good half damage
45 that's gonna put you down at three and you will also be thrown off the ship
all right you're in the water your elemental is gone I think no no it's it has 90 health
no you saved right yeah yeah you won't be thrown off but you do take like full brunt force
damage so you will be knocked prone I guess at the very least
and your elemental has 90 uh rumour can you make a deck safe there's a high decks too for the elemental
yeah all the other marines on top of the neck are dead oh they are they're all dead I don't need to make
a rolls for that 12 yeah it's gonna fail the elemental will just disappear due to the first damage
all right the thing completely explodes um and all of the marines that were manning the cannons at the
deck are like dead but the marines that are on the below deck on the cannons they're still alive
all right next is oh I just have the token for that that's it I just need to
token to roll right uh for the other marines let's see that's your whole turn right
round please say for two cane is going to start moving the ship maybe this time
all right finally finally 18 all right uh the ship starts to make uh turns and it's
evading this one because of the explosion the ship is starting to slow down uh the original
ship but it's not like completely like drinking or anything it is just out all right here we go
yeah yeah just throw them off the crew all right he didn't know what would happen yeah
all right that will be cane map teased you're still on the ship
uh yeah yeah your ship is now moving forward and this ship is starting to
slow down that's by yourself well they'll still be on the ship as well take close
how many can this is the ship have below that uh two
and you said there's three people manning each right yes
I am going to
oh look who's here you know what I actually can't do anything
what you're doing because the mouth is destroyed my whole house also
you blame your mouth look man all right uh make an acrobatics
oh my god oh no 13 uh you're gonna slip and you're gonna fall as you try to like cut one of the
ropes as you swing forward uh you just start to take a dive you're not gonna make it
all right you will immediately start drowning
oh no because of obvious reasons the first thing I come and see is bad teeth drowning really
oh you missed the whole 90 damage brother
uh all right Roma I said heard
um
and I just saw bad teeth fall in the water yep
yep I'm going to immediately try to grab a rope and throw it to him
and he can't he can't touch the rope he's thinking he's just thinking he can't grab the rope or anything
I never said I'm gonna try to last one was that okay uh can you what would that be
uh yeah throwing his dags just throw it and I'll say you have to make another to
be able to do the you know what just just do dags we'll figure out the rest later
14 won't be able to get to him especially in the water all right he's till
uh it takes like about a minute right
but he is from the surface he's just starting to drown so it's not that that far in maybe like five feet
uh all right it's loose turn and it's just going to stay there bob you turn
no
I have no idea what it's been happening all this time and what bob has been doing but right now he's
gonna take bob just shot the swivel gun this that's it
yeah uh he's gonna take the rope that Roma true grab it uh which is like bite on it with his mouth
and then die after about these okay
and at this point you're gonna tell me which skill check it is or
let me check something do you have your armor on
oh no oh no oh okay cool uh you also start drowning let's go
I have to rope in my hand yeah yeah yeah I have to rope okay okay I just need to know if he grabs
a hold of baptism because then I can just start pulling with okay you can grab him as you're also
sinking what what's the thing with the armor uh like what it's a heavy armor yeah but yeah it says
right there you can bro what do you mean not with heavy heavy armor I don't think let me check heavy
armor swimming
nope yeah
you can't uh all right as you start shrinking can you make a dex
to grab baptized at the where it is you're going to drown much faster than him because of the weight
uh but we'll see if you grab him on your way down
so Roma can pull two people out by the way two people
but it's waterway it's not waterway bro it's an armor
yeah but thanks for water yeah but okay okay Roma but you have to pull them outside of the water
onto the ship that's the problem
that's afterwards yeah yeah above the surface so they can breathe yeah yeah we'll see we'll see
um yeah you know it's gonna be right so can I get high
okay sure can you smoke in the fucking water you know what I'll give you that why not
okay go ahead roll for it
okay um 17 should you should be able to grab baptized as he's drowning
all right uh so on Roma's next journey can pull you up
uh all right next is the two cannons below deck both fire and the warship that are that is now
behind you this way is going to fire so that's six shots
uh cannon tech normal
okay miss
tech normal
how many was that miss hit i'm gonna roll for this one
two out of the three
16 doesn't hand right uh
okay one two three four five one more
16 doesn't hit your is yeah it is 15 now
yeah so 19 what's our head
anyone deflecting or no
yeah let me just go from the water no no malphous
you guys gonna miss two and a big one incoming this is your four pounder
uh so it misses not 20 okay fucking you're dead uh okay
so one
yeah yes is it 30 is it actually 30 because that's crazy it's 30 there's no way 64
no no that's 15 okay what the fuck why did i write 30 okay
i was like what there is no way it's 30 oh no no no it's showing us 30
because of double damage okay sorry um so one is maxed so that's 15 so i'm
gonna just do normally and then 150 so 76 and 150 okay you can decrease the
damage as much as you want
what do you mean can i use one of my inspiration points to power malphous
no it's only for you when at the start of the turn
didn't it show oh yes i did i don't think so
it said you did it but you did it wrong for it
this should be 30 okay okay see so that's 76 150
150 plus 76 minus how much 13
okay your ship is gonna take 213 damage
uh
how many charges do i have with the error okay you're on uh less than half
HP on the ship let me check the rules for the
damage okay so in 1 to 8 hour during repairs for each hour okay if the ship is far to 0 HP okay
we're gonna check in water okay nothing for half five
five points right below if it's half normal value the ship is irrebearably damaged and not
even the ship right can restore it to its original points maximum okay okay it's just gonna
take like a whole section off of like a part so guys our ship is bleeding can you also
can you also take uh make a deck save whoever's on the ship
like save for the saber to it fails like save for
yeah but the same pact would hit everyone it's a chunk out of the fucking ship uh 12 is not enough
13 is enough alpha says good bob is inside i'm gonna make a check for the horses
i'm gonna check we could check for Lou
you know the other sides are showing impact on that much
i'm gonna make a check for a kid
okay everyone succeeds access for Lou Linus and Cybertude Tiger
and they're gonna be knocked prone knocked prone not prone that's about it
two two only two warships
it's not a restissue you're not doing so battle you're trying to run away just so you know
all right also ask your captain don't not me all right Linus is going to get back up from being
prone and he's going to run up and he's going to grab Roma alongside with him he's gonna start pulling
on the rope when it comes the turn uh Malthus what are we doing
you can help Roma pull up or you can go
but if Linus is already giving help action you can't really help more than that
i have an idea all right i'm gonna blow so raise it ourselves
okay gust of wind you use three of your uh devil fruit power already right though
i got you guys you can use gust is it
is it a can trip yeah i guess okay you can use that yeah uh one medium or smaller
creature that you choose must succeed this or push the way a creature small blast of air okay
you're just doing it on the mast right yeah yeah you just you just blasting air into the mast
and trying to get some distance again i'll say you get maybe half of your total distance
to the next turn if the role for movement is okay all right the seabirdutes is knocked open and
it's going to run up oh no and he's going to attack you Malthus
oh no oh you're you're in the sky
all right so then it's going to attack one of the horses
that's fine that's fine
i mean there's two horse man you're gonna change your horse
seven
and a claw if it's my horse i'm just gonna get my horse to kill it
it's it's it's attacking the closest thing so it's the horse below deck not yours
it's all it's tied up so it doesn't help uh twelve and what was the first one seven
oh my god it's dead this horse is dead
all right i'm gonna be that's a great gift great good guys
all right canes turn canes going to
roll four water waco
fourteen is good enough you should be able to navigate out of here all right so the
sister baptized you can't really do anything yeah
all right let's see the people on the other ship are going to start boarding
as well let me see uh roll sixty two one will board two will not board
okay four of them board two are going to stay back and just shoot from four uh
four of them land and they are going to just start shooting
is shooting
tank one two three four five
mouth is 14 doesn't head 12 doesn't head 10 doesn't head 14 doesn't head 20 heads that's
said oh they're so bad yeah what's your minimum uh deflect that's four damage you should be
will do that yeah yeah that's there we go okay
okay the whole circus flake what's the what's the damage from the village four four
where is it
what the fuck is it
you don't don't tell me you don't have it
yeah no I have it it is what blinds just like me solstice and the features it's literally in your
favorites yeah I know about just blind okay it's not good uh fifteen what is what is 15
two oh two to attack okay yeah that will hit him
so nine minus four right
oh it's just full whatever you roll okay uh so uh you are like frying against all of them
like shooting at you uh as you dodge most of them you grab one spin around and just shoot it back
which one are you shooting at the one on the ship or the four that landed on your deck
yeah one of the one of the land is on our deck all right nine wood hit him but it won't kill him
well all right uh Roma it's your turn Paul with strength with advantage
Linus is helping I don't think he can help a lot but you know it's all it's uh whatever you need
to roll high man I'm just telling you from okay that should be good enough I think
21 yeah yeah you should be able to pull them back up uh until like uh they're out of the water
but after that you have to pull again to get them on top or they can navigate themselves on top
uh all right it's loose turn and Lu is going to see the carnage right in front of him and he's just
going to you run up uh Bob's your turn
not boy yeah can Bob just pull back to his long distance he has powerful bills so he comes
to a size higher when he's carrying something okay so can I you can Bob just carry
both veggies and get up I don't think that these needs carrying since he's above the water but can he
just get up to the deck he's still going to be weak so you can pull him up for this
okay how how are you doing there you're just letting go of the rope and going or just pulling on
the rope because if you pull on the rope Roma has to make a strength check
we're almost wrong all right pull on the rope pull on the rope make a strength check normal
same Roma can you make a strength save with the advantage yeah with advantage
strength save with advantage Roma and okay in Roma we just oh shit please again please again Roma
please again okay 14 okay uh it all depends on what your role is
that is me yes and it's uh strength save or check check check
okay it's a perfect balance as all things should be
so uh Roma you should be able to hold him uh his weight as he's pulling himself up
you're back on deck as you plump uh baptism's body onto the deck now
at least you cough off some off the water that got into your lungs but you are ready to go
what you want to I guess all right uh four cannons incoming
yay I know
uh there we go quick questions check
uh mouthfuls is able to deflect them can Bob like get in front of them and
oh I can't trade them if it's spot
I mean uh sure but can you do you have that moment speed
thing is like reactions only work when they're like targeted to
right oh okay makes sense yeah only one hit uh six eleven ten twenty yeah only one hits
all right you see like a cannon just zooming towards like the center of the ship where
Lewis and you just move your body and try to deflect that cannon all right
I think to shield Bob you need to be like in ten feet or something right
something like that okay 18 I can only shield myself so I just want to get in front of the thing
but never mind yeah okay uh 18 and what was the damage in total 23 the uh cannon like hits you
full force and you will take the remaining damage uh along with the ship
23 minus 18 so that's five you're knocked out my upteast
yep the damage went well they exploded like the big cannon last turn
all right here we go
Lou does not take any damage all right uh it's
Linus's turn he's going to run to Bob Teast and he says to you
no 20 some friends would be arriving soon uh and he's going to bring you back up
Ohhh there you go, where is it?
" *ำgenit nuts snapping their teeth*
48" so I'm just gonna roll one day eating in and just press that
I'm gonna have to use your backup with 16 HP
There you go
as
Alright, it's your turn
The four Marines are still on deck
Here and two of them are here
alongside here
Do diving in?
Right
Where are the head?
You have to take up the doing
Yeah, what the hell is he doing?
Why you think I'm doing this all?
One of the guards that were hit by the Marine that was hit by the bullet will die
Go ahead
Alright, another one
Eating a male head
Well, great
Nine
Yeah, fucking ago I'll out
Alright
It's
14? Yeah, that kills the second one
Alright, lots of deck
It's
Yeah, that will kill him
There's one more remaining
By the way, the moment
The moment how the set was going for a new character
He's starting to do huge amounts of deck
Yeah, that's crazy
Alright, that's your turn, right?
Yeah, that's me
Okay, Sabertooth is going to run up
It's going to see
No, the fucking horse isn't the way
Oh, horses buy
My horse is with Kate, right?
It's dead brother, do you not see the map?
I know, I'm talking about my horse, it's my horse dead
Pro, it's right here in front of the Sabertooth
That's what he's going to kill, I guess
My horse is at Hp of 40, I guess
Okay, 40 and AC?
AC is 15, it hits
Okay, 18 hits, 24 hits, 13 and 14
Oh shit, oh, you piece of shit
13 HP
It's alive, it's not going to be alive anymore
All right
It's on your turn, remember?
Oh, okay, alright, okay
Alright, it's Kate's turn
And he is going to
He is, but he's too busy in running away
20 HP, that should be good enough
To maintain the distance
How far are we?
You're kind of leaving the other ship behind
But not really that far away
Okay, map east
I mean, what, what?
You're the captain
You're the captain, you're calling the shorts, I thought
Well, this is the one that told him to get us out of here
He did so bad, my orders of taking care of the present
When it did that though
When you were like just do what Lines says, right?
I told Kate to keep the pet in control
No, you said get the horses in control
And he did
He did do that, he tied them down
And then Bob called his or so, it's not his fault
And then we got shot for like
Yeah, and the saber tooth cannot get out unless the cage is broken
Which is now broken, and that's why the saber tooth is out
There's still two Marines on our ship right?
One Marine, one
I killed three of them
Yeah
But this is going to take a deep breath
Get up
And make the slow, mid-assing walk towards this last glory
Get the hell off my ship
And then just explode with the ass or arms
Okay, let's make a deck save
I think he fails, right?
Yeah, he fails
So you're just going to chuck him with just the force of the astral arms
Yeah
Alright, as you walk down to this Marine
He kind of starts to back off, he's just trembling as he is not enough
It can gather enough courage to even shoot
As soon as you let your body change and morph into your void form
The force from which your astral arms appear kind of pushes the Marine into the water
Alright, there are two Marines are still on the ship that are in the fire range
That is a...
That's a bonus action
Also, don't you use up your devil fruit points
You only get your devil fruit points back after a long rest, right?
That was my subclass
So, did you not use any devil fruit you, as Melvus?
Well, I did
Then how can you do all three of your?
Well, wasn't it like, yeah, I used to try to transform
And then the amount of uses I have to like cross spells
So, should we have two?
Yeah, but you used three for the level three spell, right?
No, but I mean, wasn't it like you used one to the fourth and then the amount of uses you have to use cross spells?
No, no, no, no
One devil fruit
You can
But, you can't, but Baptist can
No, I don't know
Was that how we decided?
If you level up, you can use level three spells
You know what, I'm gonna keep the pool for casting spells and transformations different
How about that?
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about
I do feel like you used one transform and two transform that already brings it down to one point
Level fruit point, yeah
Well, think can I get more uses as a lobby?
No, you already have one more uses as a lobby, or no, you get one more uses as a parametia for spell
You get one more devil fruit uses initially, and in the fucking bulk at least, I don't know, man
Well, the bookstruck about devil fruit
What?
The bookstruck about devil fruit
Yeah, I know
I know
That's why initially I was like give them like fall abilities and whatever that you guys had against maybe not fair to be other characters
Which is there
I don't even have a complete devil fruit, because I'm supposed to get a resistance for being a lobby, but I don't have one
But we'll see later
No, you have elemental domain, right? That's part of your
No, so each lobby is resisted to their own types
Yeah, force
Your resistance for damage, right?
No, I'm not
I probably don't have on the sheet, but you are
Let me give you a force, is it?
Yeah, I'm going to change the lot
Yeah, I would have changed the lot
Your force is it now?
No
Okay, uh, what can I do?
What can I do?
I'm just going to chuck a firebolt that the ring still in range
So, Mrs
Extra attack
All right
Next are the guards
This one hits, roll the damage
That hits one of them, but it doesn't kill it, it just cinches off like one of his arms, so he won't be attacking with normal
Next turn is going to be with disadvantage
So, let me
Pistol, pistol
And then pistol, pistol again
Sorry, attack doesn't vanish
The closest probably is still you
It misses both of them, okay
You are here, how is this?
How are you back here?
I'm dead
Are you there, right?
I'm here
Um, yeah
Roma
I want Kate to make a B-line
Yes, sir
Borships still shooting less
Okay, just, just cream at Kate
There's nobody on the ship, correct?
One more guy
One more guy, one more guy
Two more guys, not on the ship, but on the other ship
Yeah, there's no way out
Not on the ship
Do you want to thing to head on?
Yeah, okay
Under two far away
Fuck it
Baptiste, take these fucking snacks, bro
What do you give me?
One, just roll
You get two of those bad boys
So that's ten more in 26
Okay, what did you make, Roma?
It's basically like a veggie
This is what I was making when we first started the battle
It's like a veggie bar
Kind of like an oatmeal bar
Nice, I think
All right, next is Lou
He's close to the sabertoot, so he's going to be you
Is he going to be the one?
Oh, Baptiste, call him
It's your turn
How far is the other ship from us?
The ship is getting pretty left behind, but it's still like trying to keep in...
So it's around here
If you can see my cursor
Yeah, but it's kind of leaving behind
Baptiste, sorry, Malthus did use gusts and everything to speed up the ship
I wanted to send my horse to the other ship
Since it's going to die the next round
But let me just...
I'm going to give it to the other horse
Yeah, I guess, yeah
You can knock back
And now the attacking the other guy is more important
How do I even do this spell?
Necrotic Bolt Beam?
Yes, please do that
All right
Okay, how do you do this exactly?
Do you still have your old arm? The mechanical one?
I do not have that arm, but I kept the arm and molded it into a gun that I have in my wallet
Yeah
I still have the can trip of told it as well
11, what are you hitting? The guy on the...
Yeah, the one that's shooting us
Okay, there are two guys, which one do you want to hit?
One looks... one has a wound on his arm
And one is not damaged at all
Non-healthy one
Non-healthy one dies
With that shot goes right through its head as it, like, the burn appears to, like, cause some smoke out of his body as it drops straight into the ocean
All right
Anything else? You have one more action
Okay, it's after melee
Okay, all right, after your turn, the ship is going to fire
Four rounds yet again
And I believe it's the third turn, right?
No, it's only been a second
So after this one, you know, yeah, attack one, two, three, four
Okay, which one's hit?
Two, one hits, you can deflected Baptist or a Malfus
Or both
16? Baptist, you're going to stop it or no?
Well, I have another plus five from DEX, none included or leveled
Oh, okay, okay, so you should be able to just blast it away from you
Okay, as the cannonballs fly straight up, you block the cannonball and just throw it directed into the water
All right, around this time you do, can you make a perception for me?
Whoever's on this side
Let me see
Eight, he doesn't notice
Roman, can you make a perception?
Yeah, I'm going to just in case make a perception
Thanks
Perception is what ability you wisdom, right?
Oh my god, is she's Christ, okay
None of you notice anything
All right, you said him, you told him to move the ship, right? Baptist?
Yes
All right
Okay, Linus will run up to you as ghosts, I don't think it's a good idea
I laid down some lure for some sea kinks, they might show up soon
And just keep going
I'm sure you that they'll come
I've used this bait a lot of times, they will come
But these are just like, look at the damage of the ships so far
If they can keep attacking without any retaliation, we won't last long
So it better be soon
It's me, it's only going to take a bit more time
All right, mouth is
Can you make another perception on your turn by the way?
Sure, good deception, there's another one
The perception is a detour
You start to see a shadow kind of like tailing the marine vessel
I'm going to look at the lines and the piece
I guess our bait works, better time to get out of here
And all the ghosts, different scales
Okay, go ahead
So it doesn't do anything
Okay, now mind, it's the saber-toothed turn
And it's going to bite
And it's going to
23 heads
18 heads
I think it might be it for your buddy
Yeah
Your horse didn't get a level second
How's that? That's not much of a problem
Yeah, but you have to get a horse
You have to actually physically get a horse, man
Technically, technically, it says find mouth
I know, I know
But you have to get something
You want the saber-toothed, you can take the saber-tooth
I don't care
But you have to, you have to tame it
You have to tame it, though
I'm not going to just fucking you
The thing that kills your horse is not your mouth
The horse is dead
And it's going to attack
Sorry
A lane to six-hurt is close
All right, Cade is going to look at you about cheese
And he's going to ask again
What are your orders?
Wait, do I sail ahead?
Or do I turn around?
Stay the course
All right, he's going to
Do the water
We go
Yeah, yeah, yeah
We're rolling bad, but it's not going to matter soon
All right, mouth, taste your turn
Well, the taste is just over
The whole situation
So he is going to start walking below deck
And in his path just happens to be the saber-toothed
Yeah
[Laughter]
Uh-huh
Please, don't kill it at least
Please, just calm down
I mean, you can knock it out
You can knock it out, it's up to him
Honestly
12 is not going to hurt him
I don't think
It is, it is AC
So it's not going to hurt him
That's going to hurt him
It's pain
12 not
[Laughter]
Well, if he hits it, he's going to be like
Stop or move
Can he do an intimidation?
He's going to be able to do it
[Laughter]
Okay, uh, as you just
calmly walk toward him
You throw your astral arms to its body
One of them hits him right in the jaw
As all of the others are kind of like holding it up
As you ask it to like get out of your way
It kind of like
Uh-uh
Wines a bit
As you put it down
It just got else away into like the broken down gauge back inside
[Laughter]
You know, these are just like what they hear on his face
And keep moving down below deck
All right
[Laughter]
It's going to be you
There's still one guy on the ship
And right about this time
I'm going to make a fate roll for this guy
[Laughter]
All right
And
No, no, no
I added some roll
It doesn't, yeah, it doesn't really work that way
Let me see
I need to make copies of this guy too
You know, I'll just roll one D
Roll one D
[Laughter]
You look younger
Six, okay
The shadow beneath the ship that was following
The marine vessel starts to get bigger and bigger
As you see, this seeking has nothing
In common with the seeking that you have fought so far
Baptiste or Malthus
The seeking is completely uncovering the whole space that the warship is on
And the warship is very big
Way bigger than your ship
As the seeking with like a serpent
Kind of mouth, kind of wraps around the whole vessel
And it takes like two of the cannons from the top deck
Completely out with his like first bite
And just starts going ham again
And again and taking chunks out of this big ass warship
As it completely stops after a point
And it's gonna be
The end of the encounter
Once I see the seeking, I'm gonna yell "cranted"
"cranted"
I'm just gonna turn the caterer quick
Yeah
That's your goal
Oh
Tame is deacon
And then I'll go below deck
I can't, I can't really do that
I'm not saying like right now
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know
But he's still gonna be like "okay, that's stupid"
I can't do that
All right, you are below deck
I think I should start to patch up the ship
Maybe later
He gets off and starts to like
Find whatever he can patch
And just starts moving
And like basically close up the holes that he can find quickly
And just board it up
As soon as he can
Let me make carpenter jewels normal
Oh my god
Okay, it's gonna not work
All right, that's great
I'm gonna switch the music for once again
Uh, calm
All right
Everything settling down
What is everyone doing?
Baptiste is headed back into the world cave
But we've dubbed
[laughs]
All right
Bob
Bob has Tinker's tools provisions
So can he help uh, cage
Patch up the ship?
Uh, sure, let me just re-roll the carpenter jewels
It's not really good at it
Because he's not a ship right
But you can try
Okay, yeah, that's good, that's good
He can easily like patch up some of the holes
And remember that the ship has taken irreparable damage
Unless it's given to like a uh, uh, uh
Like you have to completely like spend actual money to repair it now
Instead of just time
So, the 50 million, the plans
The plans are out of the
[laughs]
Out of the question now
All right, um
Okay, you are helping, Cade
A Roma, what are you doing?
A Roma, Roma, Roma
Shit, I'm cooking like always
I'm gonna go into the kitchen
I'm gonna start making the food for everybody
All right, um, Malfus
But first off, you gonna see me all the way
Both those two dead horses
Okay
Right, there we go
Rushmean
It's gonna last us a long while
All right, uh, Malfus
Uh, I guess getting the saber to it back in its cage
Yeah, but the cage is completely broken
It's kind of scared into a corner, but you know, it's not really locked
What are you doing?
I'll just keep a lookout for now
I'll still follow you or not
Uh, look out on top of the ship
Yeah
Can we sit in the macros, Mass?
All right, Linus is going to follow you in, uh, Baptiste
Oh, thank you for trusting me
I know it
Might have not sounded like the best decision, but
This is what it is
Anyway
What's the plan moving forward?
Uh, right around that time you hear
Isim kind of shuffling
Uh, like out of the room that she was in
She goes, "The hell was that?"
Ah
Let's get him a rascade
All right, I mean, I knew they were
After me, but this is a bit too much for me
Uh, Linus at this point opens the door
And uh, shows uh, Vorotide up
And he goes, "Starting to make more sense now
What were you thinking?"
Baptiste, I'm asking you what the fuck were you thinking?
Getting a captain
On to the ship
I don't have time for this right now
Okay, so look, if you just wanted to get me killed anyway
Why did you even bother like sending, come to my rescue
Isim? Okay, do whatever you want
She just goes back into the room and just slams the back walls
You can understand why she was
It's like in my door
You can understand why she would be distressed by seeing the sky here
Uh, he like scratches his beard as he gets inside the room with you and closes the door
He's still unconscious, and you want me to wake him up?
I'm no idea to rest first
Okay, do you want me to move him outside?
Leave him there
Okay, look, Baptiste, I'm not gonna tell you how to run your crew
But I don't think it's a wise decision to keep captain on your ship
Regardless if they can follow us or not
He has shown that he does not care for lives or dies
Keeping him here just puts you and everyone on the ship and as much peril as Warro is in
Think about it, get some rest
I'm gonna get some medicine and put it in your room before I leave
Also, I'm gonna take these vials and maybe get something out of it
At the very least
Uh, I'm curious that they were completed corrects
He did say that, completed in what terms?
I do not know
Look, I, I will not encounter one of these serums and that was five years ago
So, we'll see, I'll have to see that what the composition of these serums are
I'll have your answers by tomorrow
So, get some rest
And then he's just going to open the gate and just head out
Don't take them along rest
Okay, uh, around this time you will hear Kate running back down and he goes
So, what, whether you're Arden, Captain, do we still just keep going away from the island?
If so, where?
We need to get the ship fixed as soon as we can
The Trojan style is set into weeks correct
Well, it's set two weeks back when we got the newspaper a couple of weeks ago
A week ago
So, it's gonna be a week, I suppose
That doesn't leave much time to get the repairs done
No, it does not
Uh
Captain, you're orders
We either need to get away from the island or we either need to hide somewhere
We can't, we can't stay like this and the ship cannot go any faster
Find us if we place the hide
Our best place to ambush the ship carrying a drone before the ride to the island
Ambush on transit is not a great idea especially in this condition
The ship will sink if it gets into another combat
We could take that ship, we don't have much of a chance at the moment
Much other options
I will ask Melthus to spot somewhere that we can ride the ship for the meantime
I'll try to do my best but I am not a skilled ship right now
I don't know how to navigate this ship
But I'll try to figure something out
He heads out as well
He will come up to you Melthus and just relay all this information
Oh, guess I'll look at some maps and see if there's something nearby
Okay
Roll the navigation tools and he's going to help so just roll it with advantage
Linus would at this point come up to you Bob
And he asked you if there is some place that he can continue working
13 with advantage
Bob
Yeah, somewhere I can set up my tools and supplies
Sort of a laboratory of sorts
Yeah, you can set up in my room
There's all sorts of tools there
I can't believe so yeah
As soon as you say that it turns around and it looks
You don't look too good my friend do you want me to check you out
I already got checked out but it's for the offer
It's just how I am never mind
All right
Yeah, you will hear Lou run up to you in your room
Baptiste as he just start just curls up near the end of your bed
And he also starts to sleep
Why does it say Melthus
Here, oh that's your token thing
No, you're aero
Linus will set up his supplies in Bob's room
And
Rome is cooking
You're trying to figure out where to hide
You're not really going to find anywhere to hide out
Either you sail away from New Souls and Lexi Imperia
Or you try to come up with something else
There's like for like leagues and leagues you just find
nowhere to
Like stay low
It's either like marine encampments
Or just nothing just open sea
Yeah
All right, do you want to skip to next day then
It should be about like evening time
So I'm going to say the next eight hours and you just wake up at like six or something
All right long rest long rest
Yeah
Somehow I survived that as well
Oh my god
Oh by the way you guys read the newspaper straight
You would have gotten that newspaper somewhere around like when you were listening to the conversation as well
All right, everyone good
Yeah, everyone long rested
Linus did not take a single head I'm going to long rest the fucking save truth
I mean he was also you know trying to save your asses by the way
That sheet of
What do you mean that piece of shit?
Is it a real truth?
It's not gonna let it like die it's going to heal him up
What what are you saying sorry
You're cutting off of
I need the favorite foods
Oh, I'm sorry
Okay, you can go and interact with the sabre truth
Elon Musk is doing like
Okay, sorry, what are you trying to do?
I want to write it
No, no, Kate is asking you
Are you sure the captain is fine with this
The captain just punched a hole in this guy's head I'm pretty sure he is fine but yeah I can go and talk to him about it
I mean if it's captain's fine I can do whatever
So you just want him to become
Why do you put all of this shit around him?
I need you to help me keep him calm while I put all this shit around it
Okay, I'll try sure
Okay, he's gonna do animal handling
Okay, beautiful
He brings in like some of the horse meat from the kitchen Roma do you have anything to say to that?
Who is it? Is it Kate? Yeah, it is for Rob
Oh shit as long as Bob gets to eat his horse first
I'm a pair of nice little horse steak
Okay, the little one that is salt, the grill marks
I won't make sure Bob has to take a bite of it and be like
You got to eat your friend
Well, technically he wasn't exactly my friend and I am hungry so yeah
All right
Can you roll cooking utensils?
Oh hell yeah, I hope it tastes like that
It doesn't matter if you roll the meat that as well because I don't need to eat
You don't need to eat but
It's time to go
Not 20 holy shit
It's like even if you can taste it
It's just sends signals to your brains that it's good
He's the best thing you ever had
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I can't take a horse
Yeah, yeah, it is Bob done
Yeah, I'm gonna find a little piece of fancy ribbon
Running my fat ass down to baptises room
All right, I know that's for a lot of this and I know where that's where baptises
All right
So Bob, what are you doing?
You just tying him up or do you just want to keep him distracted with the food
I'm as he is eating the food time of birth and then
And through
All right, can you make a just a stretch?
I check normal
I love to and remember I am you have given me a lot of time
For which I'm grateful
1d4 damage but it does not really change anything
Do you have 20 strength?
No, but I can't get yeah, I can get more strength
No, okay, no, you can get only up to 20
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
So just friendship
Yeah, let me do the normal
That is beautiful, unlucky 13
unlucky 13 is not enough, let me check actually
Here's a base score of 18, but I'm gonna roll anyway
Oh my god, no
It's going to resist, it's going to not let you grapple it
Can you do it, can you roll again and let's say this time Kate is helping
Okay
Okay, I'm gonna roll for him again
Can I with my bonus action since it's an action from it with my bonus action
Can I cast it?
No, no, it's it's already
Yeah, okay, you tie him up and I'm gonna say you are able to kind of control him for now
All right, Rooba, what are we doing?
Let me do the
Oh, you know what I'm doing
And I'm running down
So I'm gonna hit his head and turning him into like a mini
Falcon sky, Frankenstein, mini cyborg
What, are you gonna kill him?
What are you doing?
I'm gonna hit him into like a Frankenstein like a mini cyborg
Okay
Okay, so you can change the
You don't need to change the sad block, right? Is this the same step block?
Always the same
Okay
All right, Rooba
So your name is Pegasus now
All right, cool, let me change the name
I guess it doesn't fit but all right
The name, I can just use this normal sad block that was in the sheet
But it's different
No, but it has different stuff, slam, trampling, charge and all that
Yeah, so the find mount's that block that is
It remains the same, okay, okay, okay, it remains the same, that's what you're saying, right?
Yes, okay
All right, Rooma
I'm running down to Baptiste's room
All right
Like I'm the police, you here
You're the only one for you, Baptiste
Wake up
Dad, I know you're in there again, freaky, come on now
Come on, Captain
Uh
Got food for you, I got food and milk, come on now
Don't make me break your dough down
Make sure to fucking kill me
Oh, I can hear him
That's just slowly getting up
Walk towards the door and open it and just give Rooma the hardest layer of it, you can pass a manage
I'm here for the OG
I know we have in sexual torture, I brought silk like Lyna said, you needed
Lyna says in this room
I thought he was following Baptiste
Where's Lyna said, he said we're sexually torturing this dude
He needed silk
And I know you getting freaky diggy down here with the candles, come on now
Lyna says in Bob's room
Where's Bob's room?
He's just gonna sway him to door in his face
He's just staving this man all to himself
I'm here for the torture
Save more of Master one
No, the mask was back there, it was completely shattered and it was back there
So is he gonna walk past and just smack him to knock him back out?
I don't know
I'm running into Lyna says the room
All Baptiste can hear is fat footsteps
Okay, let's do this first then
Okay, we were headed to Bob's room
Is that where Lyna says?
Yes, that's where Baptiste would have pointed you to
I'm getting the Bob's room, I'm not even knocking, I'm swinging that fucking door open
I thought we were sexually torturing this dude
And now you said you need rope now we're doing nothing
You was going to tease a fat man
I think I'm done for now Roma
We should take that to Baptiste
You see in the room it's just like completely like filled with smoke
and just disgusting smells
Your nose kind of perks up as soon as you enter the room
And you just see him mixing some chemicals on this table
At the edge of it
It seems to be like he has been awake for the whole night
Question, does that smell familiar?
Like when I got shot with that stuff on that island?
No, no, it's like just weird like sense of just musk sweat and all of that
It doesn't smell familiar to the liquid that you get in here
It's sweat, I'm good I'll be like
Why is this smell like stacked in here?
And I ain't getting none
What the fuck is this?
Roma, just impatient
You know I know some places
I know some places that we can maybe visit at one point
But today is not the day unfortunately
I'm just going to grab whatever he is fucking mixing and just chugging
Oh god
I'm just going to take it and drink it and be like
Listen here motherfucker, you promise me
If I brought this and then whatever happens happens
Like if I pass out
Let me see
Okay, where were the ones that you guys had?
Green, black, white and red, right?
Yes, don't remember
Okay, the white one
Let me see
I have a tape somewhere
Yeah, you chuck down the white serum
Though he was working on currently
Let me see
Oh, what is it?
God damn it, I keep
No, it's like kind of like dusty
Kind of like the bone dust
Kind of that you saw before
Okay
Can you make a con save Roma?
Please let me go crazy
No, it would have been wisdom but it's just con
So it's not, it's just going to affect you
Whatever it is
Yeah, you'd ask me out and one fuck
Oh god, oh god, oh god, I didn't want to...
Okay
You feel like something's wrong
Something's very, very wrong
As your body kind of like loses its weight
And the fur kind of like
Goes back in your skin
And human skin starts to appear
After a while
Roma?
You are not a man anymore
You are human
Why?
What's up with you and turning every human?
Are you like a human supremacist or something?
No, I mean if he rolled anything better than this, it would not happen
But yeah, you turn human and we just...
I lost my devil fruit power
No
No, wait, what?
Why would you lose your devil fruit power?
Your devil fruit is a yeti
Yeah, you are a man
I'm still going to get better
And you don't know if this is permanent or not
What did you fucking do to me, Lina?
You chucked the thing
What were you living before?
I guess it's just...
You gonna...
It didn't even know what it would do
At least
You need a fish three
Okay, as soon as you try to grab him, he just phases right through you
And he puts both of his hands in front
This is not permanent
I hope
He said I hope
At least we know what this thing does
And now that we are aware of what it does
We can revert whoever turns monsters
Right?
So maybe we take a win
I'm gonna be like, hold on one second
One second, I'm gonna lift my pants up
I'm gonna be like
Mm-hmm
You just...
You just see Roma looking up and down, up and down, up and down
And then you see it like reaches hand in there
To feel everything
And you hear like one, two
Okay, no third
Okay, we good
And then you see him pull his hand out
Like try to measure like on his arm
Tip to elbow
Like you see him do that
He got bigger
Good for you, my friend
Well, was there anything else you wanted to
Discuss
You better turn me back
You better fuck off the back
I guess we just wait and see
What else you got?
What's next?
I think this...
Okay, for today that's...
That should be enough
I'm gonna turn around, take a step and just pass the fuck out
Okay
It's okay
Fuckin' done
No, that is...
No, that's what I was planning to do today
Can't someone help me with this?
You see kind of yells
Okay, so I'll go
All right, you enter
And as soon as you see like a different like human being
Or like what the fuck is happening?
Yeah, exactly
What the fuck is that?
It seems to be your friend drank one of these
And he is human now
Makes sense
These are made for
Minks is blood
So I suppose they found maybe a reverse agent
To drill down the mutation, whatever mutation they have
Well, I'm gonna go back to work
You've taken back to his station or whatever
Thank you, Melfus
And he starts working back again
Oh, guess I'll do that
Yeah, I guess he's a dragon and put him there
All right
Baptiste, you were saying something I cut you off
Are we using?
It was
You were saying something when I was talking with Roma
Let's move on if you don't remember
Okay
As soon as you turn around like shut the door and turn around
He looks
To you and
Was it fun?
I see those wounds
It could not have been
An easy fight
But this is gonna walk slowly up to him
And then like grab his chin
And make him look in the eyes
You notice like
It took care for someone
To have people you need to look after
Not for selfish reasons
But
The children will pass you walk too
And you call yourself Pirate
You're nothing with a weakling little bird
You're gonna die
This world is gonna kill you and spit you out
Baptiste is gonna start a claim in his hand
Like walk you grab you just
Sid
See
You're the one you
Are the ones who gave me the title of Pirate
I never claim that title myself
But you did
You will join the Black Hand Pirates of your own will that teased
He's gonna intends to fight a flame
So burn him even more if he starts talking while I'm still
Okay
You see
You try to say that I'm weak
But
There's some things that
Weakness allows you to see
And yet
You're the one who's always defeated
I mean look at you right now
In the grasp of my hands
And then with his other hand he's just gonna snap
Pirates is gonna burn him and remain closed he has on
It's too hard
Okay
There's something
Vulnerability
Related
You wanna act like you're tough
And then he's gonna remain closed
And I am going to destroy him
Just like what you wanted to do to me
I'm going to destroy you 10 bolts
Then I'm gonna intends to fight a flames in my hand on his face
And then with my other hand I'm gonna like start carving the symbol
Of the Winnipew Pirates on his chest with flames
Okay
You're gonna brand him
So as you do that the screams fill
Like the complete like halls
And the deck with the
Voro scream and everyone can like hear
Like the sing that you're carving into
Voro
And yeah, me
You do that
You can you
How does the field be caged?
You think you can break me
Don't
Fall yourself
He's like kind of at this point struggling to even breathe
He still gets these words out
You are
Not me
And he's gonna pass out
As soon as he say that
I'm gonna just hit your back when you fall in his back
And you said he passed out
I'm just gonna leave him one of them when he's back right now
And sorry, Edden here
I'm just gonna leave him laying for the back
Oh, that's up
Oh, you'll soon find out just how much I am
All right
You cap
What's the game plan now
You can go up and know mouth as you can fill him in that you could not find any place to stay or like hide
After baseball
Oh wait, but these goes up
I'll come out of the world
If my face tells you don't just go
Well, going back to the island is a no go
Ain't no our ship, they know our faces
So obviously meeting them in the sea is the option
As we go, looks around at the ship
So we know not many choices
But the goal is still the same
We still need to rescue driving
Let me see that newspaper again
Oh, grab it
Probably our eyes on the road
The place where the six holes is spotted
How far is that from here
That's in the south blue, brother
Yeah
Never mind
They were expecting to get some backup
Maybe
Okay
This barren
What do you know about him
It is the vellant crew's succession now
It's Baron Lazarus assumes authority
Falling in the southern death of Baron Lazarus
Lazy El Baron crews
Leadership of villain crews has passed on to his second son
The new appointed Baron Lazarus
Vellant crews has formally assumed control of the family holdings in Diffrode
It is expected to attend the upcoming hundredth trial of Lex Imperial
Where his presence is set to represent continued cooperation between Diffrode families
And the government officials have described this visit as a gesture of good faith and stability
Stability following recent events
Is there a picture attached with his injury
Let me link the picture
Link at the big
Okay
Is it the ninja news?
Good news of villain
Okay, god damn it
Here it is
The arch
The crystal crystal there we go
There you go
Do I recognize him?
You don't recognize the face now
Obviously we need to get back to the eye
The sea battle is not in our best interests ever right now
The only other option is the island
One of the chances
The one we have
Can get us onto the ship
He's been unconscious since we've gotten here
But it doesn't have to ask
I'm pretty sure he'd be willing to assert himself
Let's give him a visit
So you walk to the room where Dravos was in Dravos
He would be put into the cage room
So you can try knocking or you can just walk in
Yeah, every NPC has a room
Yeah, I'll knock
And then we have a little bit of a space where we can get a room
And then we have a space where we can get a room
Oh, real feeling
Why did not see you come in
I want to come ocean outside
Is it really hard?
Good, good
I am still a bit exhausted
Did you find any information about my brother?
He has to go men in case 12 or about a week
Okay, that's good. We have time. We can board up
We can go to the island and then we hide
And no wait for him to show up again
The board and the island might be a bit difficult right now
What was the point? Did I transport you to a difficult location?
No, it was the right place
But some things happened in the meantime
So what are you suggesting then?
I don't know. I don't know.
As soon as you say that, he's like visibly see his expression kind of like changes
And just from like alert to just like fearful as he goes
But I don't know if that's such a good idea
You can just take them if you do attack
But the thing is, can you get us on the ship?
Powers to make
I can't even use my powers right now after I try to get up and maybe move
But it's not working
Be of any of you in some of the week, it's a long time
But I won't be able to help you with my fault points
And all you would need to do is get us all deep to ship
Do you know any information like what for the traveling crew?
The thing is, if you name this strike zone, information is probably a guarded warship
And what you in the ship, because then that's guarded by sea stone
That's why they do that to prevent any devil fruit abilities to get inside
So that's some of the question
If we have worked together on the deck, then might also help get in the amount of surprise
And to prepare the contract
I understand what you're saying
But I can't teleport you inside
Do you understand that?
We just need to get on
Because I use my ability to teleport the two great distance
I can only do it within 120 feet
What that should be possible
Good work, give it a try tonight
I need to speak with Linus
But it should be possible
I just want to get a reassurance
I just want to get some rest just in case we go in with a plan
It means to keep me updated about my brothers status if you could
Don't worry
Good thing it hasn't changed
I appreciate your...
You've gotten far and beyond to save my brother
I will never forget this
Thank you
All right
What do you want to do now?
I want to go see Linus
As you're walking back to Linus' room, you see him head out
Close the door
As he kind of lunged
Squats down and coughs
A bunch
And he was...
That was pretty bad
I would suggest to not go inside that room for a while
Do you have another one?
Another one of what?
The lore
I mean...
That was the last of my supplies
But we can't gather some materials and we can't make it up again
Are they hard together?
Well...
One of them, yes, we do need
Some organs from a smaller seeking
So nothing we can get done with the missing?
No, I do not think so
It should be enough
To know the location where you want to deploy it
It would be hard to deploy it near the shore
As the seeking is mostly live away from civilization
At least in the north anyway
If we can manage to make the lore first, then everything else will be able to bottom-lace
But if we don't have one, there's no point in discussing it at the moment
What's the post on?
So what exactly is the plan?
Well for starters, we need to
That's just things to be prepared
Well to be honest, there's no plan right now
There's no nearby island where we can go to
We can't help out until the ships get here
We can't really go back to the island
The only things I have in mind are
Far more risky than
Well, it's what they're to do
The naked I do have a captain on my ship
So then I can't really say much
And there's a reckless, I would say
But you don't kind of remind me of an old friend at least
Maybe we take risks for a reason
And maybe you will find their way somehow
Anyway, well I found out one of what one of the serums do
He like dangles the white serum and he looks at you and goes
Well if you find any of the mutated monsters
Any more than just inject them with these
And it should revert back
Interesting
You might want to go have a look at the kitchen
There's some things rising here
Did the biscuit look undeserved?
It is not going to back, let's say it like that
That's all I need to know
Anyway, if any of you do need medical assistance
Let me know I will be going to the top deck to get some fresh air
He starts to walk up and he was going to get out of sight
Alright
I have two ideas in mind
Okay, you can discuss them with Malfus
One
You return the way we came
The
Mansion
The secret entrance that we used to
The secret entrance that we used to begin in
It wasn't that
Barried in
And to the honest
That family didn't finish that strong either
Well, the
Cave entrance probably going to be more guarded right now
There's a day scene that's coming out that way
But they also
Know that we would track down
So the thing I plan on thinking of is
We assault that mansion, take it over
And use it as a base on the island for the moment
My other plan
Involves the novel
In the newspaper
If we can find his ship before he arrives
Because he used him to smoke ourselves on the island
Hmm
Both plans are risky
I do admit
At this point
I don't know if we'll be able to have safer measures
To get what we need done
As you're talking
You hear like the door kind of slam open
And you see him
Come outside
As soon as you said the first thing I was thinking
Is he fucking stupid
But then you said the second thing I was like
Okay, maybe he's not that stupid
Also you judge, I do need to be aware that I am a spy
And I will be listening so I'm going to stop apologizing for this
So yeah, continue
Teaching barging just to say that
No, I was barging in to help you
Because you dip-shits
Don't have anything or any sort of idea
Is the what to do
Then what do you know about this third velcro
Alright, the new baron or whatever
Okay, look, I wasn't a prison for quite a while
So I don't know who this fucking guy is
I do know the baron that was
Ruling driftroot though
I am originally from the east
So I do keep tabs on the islands
And driftroot is one of the closest islands
From a spirit cliffs and
Low towns, so I know a little bit about it
Some history here and there
But I do find it weird that
The name of the new baron is not matching the name of what's baron
I thought it would be
I mean we can try but
Now we have to look for his location
So they said that he would be arriving when
I'm just tossing the news paper
Alright, well see he was supposed to be at my hearing
Which should occur anytime
Today in the afternoon
So he would be getting close to the island right about now
How far away from the island are we
In the chase if it
We got to like the 8th or 9th turn
So it would be like 5 miles per turn
Approximately
So that would be 50 miles
It's pretty far away
You won't be able to see the island
It's that far away at least
It would take maybe half an hour
So to get back to where you were attacked essentially
Yeah
Does the position we were in
Probably the third place is the Amadena
About a day
Yeah that just put us in a
Difficult position
Now only if we can find a way to
Track him down somehow
Well captain
Of course
Do you let all women do your job
Just the nosy wounds
I suppose I could come up with something
I'm not really doing much am I
Alright, a big guy
Come on follow me
Some following him
Alright
How long has Roma been knocked out
Roma should be up by now
Not that long maybe 2-3 minutes
Oh no he's passed out
Like he's passed out
I mean it's up to you however long you want to be passed out for
I was gonna say like 3 hours
No, alright
When 3 hours happen let me know
Or unless it helps me up ahead of time
Bob do you have to go
He already left again
No no I think he's here
Yeah he's here like cold
Bob
Bob where?
Clean my dinner good night
Alright alright
It's not gonna be a lot
It's just gonna be normal stuff
And then for like the main plan
We'll just do next week
Yeah
He'll fill you in
Yeah okay
Alright
We hours would not have passed
By now so I guess him is going to show
Malphys what the hell to do
Alright so
We got how long have you been the navigator
Oh for this ship
How long has it been?
Well you were a navigator in training
So maybe like 2-3 months at max
Yeah
Okay okay
Throw me your periscope
I have it
What's that?
If you actually go what's that
I'm gonna lose my mind
No, I got
Okay well my eyes all busted up
So I can't really make much
Ouch
Um
Alright here's the plan
Can you carry another person
While you you know
Do your bird stuff
I'll be slower
Okay
Alright well
Get it up
Okay
Uh
Oh
Yes all carries in
Uh
So he just yells down
She's gonna just climb on your shoulders
And she's gonna go well
Let's go
Uh he's gonna shout to you, Baptiste
And she goes
We'll be back
In a bit if he doesn't die
And I don't die then you know
It's gonna be fine
I can't really fly when you're on back
Oh okay
Where the hell do you want me to be yet?
I guess I'll just scoop around
Okay
Oh
Alright take me to dinner first
Damn
Better dip a finger while you can
Alright
Um
Alright up we go she's going to
Ask you to go to word
Where you guys
Uh like came from like to word the island
And she's going to go
Um okay
Can you go a bit higher like maybe behind the clouds
So no one can spot us
Alright
Uh while there way
Uh Baptiste
Baptiste, Roma
Bob is gone
Uh what is everyone doing?
Well like I said it's not somebody who wakes me up
Rome was gonna be passed out for like three hours
Because you're not
Uh you feel someone licking your face
[laughs]
Someone licking my face
Yes
So I'm gonna come to him you're like
Baby baby baby
Oh baby come on down
Come on down
As it try to grab whatever it is
It kind of bites your finger
[laughs]
Oh what I'm gonna bite
I'm gonna wake up
[laughs]
Kind of growls at you
He doesn't recognize who you are
It's a lure who is it
It's a lure
I'm gonna use my animal handling
And be like calm down
Calm down it's Roma
Come on, come on
Roll, roll, can't have that in there
Uh
Come on
[laughs]
Here's the that
And the one in there
How's that?
[laughs]
There it is
It's all the way at the top
I'm looking all the way at the bottom
Try for it
All right
He should calm down, settle down quickly
And he just kind of like
Uh jumps at you and he starts lick your face again
And I'm just going grab him
And he just pet his belly
Be like where the fuck is everybody
Come on move
He's just going to jump and take you to my taste
My taste, you are on the deck
Yes
All right, he's just gonna take you to my taste
First off, before I go there, I'm gonna check
Baptiste's room
If he isn't there
Oh no
I mean, he would spot you before you head in
He's like on the deck
He'll see you move in
Unless you want to stealth
No, because I just wanted to
I was in his door's lock, there's no point
Because I was going to see you
And then I was going to tie a
He won't just leave a
a prisoner in the open room, right?
Well, you know
Yeah
Where's he gonna go?
He's on the middle of the fuck to nuffle there
Oh wait, he is a captain, he can manage
Actually, I would have been inspecting his car this whole time
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah
Can you do investigation?
A light has already moved to a track at the place
Yeah, but he has this one
Yeah, the tracker is gone
But you can still look around
Maybe I don't know what you're looking around for
Okay, what are you exactly looking for?
I'm looking at it to like see how it works
And how it can be like
Like it could be
It's part of it to see if it could be selfish
And just something else as well
Okay
So how it works is
You see like the blue liquid that you saw in those machines
Back in Kalesto
That is essentially the basic like energy supply
But this thing runs on
So as soon as you run out of whatever
You have right now in the tank
You won't be able to run it again as you can imagine
And inside you just see like a weird like mechanical engine
Connecting like the axle to the wheels and every like
Bit and
No kidding
And inside you do see like a small like
Kind of
Like indented into
Broken sort of
Dendin mushy because of like all the crashing and everything
So was hidden into like a compartment that would like
Go up and show up
While like he was driving and whatever
You do see where Linus like pulled the
Tracker from that that wheel
And nothing really much you see other than like
It kind of has like this
Weird wiring going around that like tracks
Who like enters and who exits the thing
While he's looking at that
I'm trying to
Break into his door
All right
Steltly or just like freaking just
Both
Like if I don't get the stealth
I'm just going to try to quick and quick smash bash
Do a stealth check first
Nice nice
Okay
Try to like maybe just jam your frying pan
And just bolt it open
Just rolls for the frying pan
Normally
That is not going to do it but you have more tries
Yeah, more tries
Do it one more time
Before going into rage
I see the second one will actually throw you into rage
That's the exit
Rage friends, you try again
Oh my god but that will break it
Yeah, you just open up like the lock
Just break the lock completely bust in the door
As you open the door you see like a
A naked voro just lying sideways on the floor
Oh no, it's going to get even better
So I'm going to take
I'm going to look at Baptist sheets
I'm going to rip long strands of it
So it's almost like a thin cloth
And I'm going to
Is voro passed out still?
I can do a perception
He appears to be from
Black and completely not
Okay, so I'm going to
You go left at this one
I'm going to tie the string
One section underneath his nut sack
The other section behind the door
A Baptist door
So when he goes to pull his door closed
He is going to
Yank the shit out of voro's nuts
Give him a Tennessee neck tie
All right
Okay
So you are going to rip the sheets
And you're just going to grapple them
No, I'm just going to tie it around his balls
Tie it around the handle
You're putting the seed back up at the earliest
What?
He's knocked down in the chair, the chair is like
So
You want to keep him there at the bottom or what are you?
Yeah, I'm picking it
I'm setting him upright
I'm scooping his nuts on my hand
tying it around his nuts
All right, can you make a deck safe?
Yes
Hell yeah
He's going to shoot it long door to you
20, you will take half of this damage
As you like try to
Like get to his
Like balls
Right
He like breaks open from the rope
That was like kind of
Attached to the foot of the chair
And he's going to take
Tempest kick towards you
Okay
So as
I'm going to take half of that
Half of
But I'm also raging so I'm going to take half of that as well
Because it's
I think you do right
It is not a melee attack
It is a ranged attack
But what kind of what do you
Bloodgeny
It is
Sleshing
So that's perfect
Because so that's going to be half right
Yeah
So that's a 5, isn't it
No, isn't it 24
24, 12 and 6
Right
So half, because I've
Okay, so hold on
It'd be 36
Half of that would be
Now it's 24, where are you seeing 36
There's other damage right there
Where
The damage is 24, other right
Yeah, yeah
No, the other is the
The half I think
Oh, so that it would just be 6 right
Yeah, yeah
And it's just 6
Okay
You take 6 damage as
Like a win
Sleshing just like cuts up your chin
And he kind of wakes up and goes
How the fuck are you
And I'm going to remember you
Alright
Black him
You need to do a minimum kind of damage to knock him out
I'm so again twice
But I don't get it first time
By this point you will hear the slash
By the way, at least
Alright, go ahead
You know what?
I'm going to make sure I hit him
Okay, right
Close me
Alright, not 20
Do the damage
Is he
Okay, how much of it is
Fire
Fire is 8
So 10, he's going to use
A key point
Remember to max
Of the roll of the dice
Yeah, since it's a crit
So 8
Okay, so max roll would be
And 12
And 6
16, 12, and 6
That's 34
And 12
So out of 52, 20 is fire
Amish, that he will take complete
So it's going to be
And then the other one
He's going to use a
He'll get that to half
That's
32, half will be
Is he knocked out
Because if not, I'm swinging again
He will be
Okay
As soon as you like
Smack him right in the head, he knocks out
So that's unconscious
Because I know that he's had to have heard that
He's had to have heard that
He'll have to have quickly tied it to his balls
And then I'm going to jump on that
Tease is dead
While you're doing that, you see
12 his fingers are missing
What the fuck
My man linus
With his night play
All right, you do that
You
Tie it to the door
All right, now is that teased
Do I get there before
While he's still there
No
You would have
You wouldn't be able to see what he was doing
So I just see him in the room
Yeah, you don't see him in the room
Shut the door, so when you open it, you will pull
I'm investigating, so I'm just going to open the door
No, but
The minute you open it
It's going to fucking yank on his balls
Okay, ball damage
I need to search for ball damage
Uh, damage, dnd
I'm going to do it privately
Just because
It's going to be 1D4, it's supposed to be improvised
So I'm just going to roll
Can you roll 1D4 damage for me, Roma?
Fuck Max damage
Yeah, as soon as you like yank
He's going to wake up as he screams
And you like see the
Blood and grime
Sprayed all over
Your room, that teased
What?
Uh, what's this?
Roma is going to be sitting at like
Palo clenched his hands facing the wall
Just fucking giggling
Hold on, Roma, you're in my bed right now
Yes
This is the same Roma that is currently a human, correct?
And you've been seeing him like that before
Yeah, you didn't see him
If I see the person in my bed
It is someone I don't recognize
Well, you're going to see the clothes
You're going to see my clothes
You're going to see the clothes
But it's up to you, you're still up to you, you're the character
Do I see the clothes of the person first?
The role of the person in the eye
I mean, it's the busiest face
And it's like what the fuck
Yeah
He's only able to see my back
Because I have my back turned to him
Yeah, yeah
You won't be able to see the fur or anything
So you're just essentially seeing Roma's shape
Yeah
Okay, this is coming to us
Okay
All right
I see the shape
Mm-hmm
And I just go
Mount is left
Bob is upstairs
Doesn't look like Linus
In their chuggling
Roma
Does he, do you turn around with what I say your name?
Like what Bob?
I'm going to go punch
Is a, we're all like screaming in agony right now
He is, he is
Oh, good
It's a one, two
Oh, that hits
That does it
Yep
So it's going to be one of those scenes where like Baptiste just punches him
And just Roma just fucking
Bumps into like all of the room
Like a fucking ball
All right, I got a takes
Yeah, you've got to take it
What kind of damage is that Baptiste?
It just says damage
There would be bludgeoning
So let's just do half of that
Let me, let me, let me and do
And do, there we go
And then
Let me see, Roma
Half
Eight, eight, eight
Wait, I think we take the upper limit
But it's fine, the foundry automated a sadda as eight so it's fine
That's what he did that was
All right
Tell me that wasn't funny
What was the commotion I heard
He woke up so I had to hit him real quick
You can see his legs untied
You got this boss
You need me to whack him again
I'll go and tie his legs back up
Go find me more rope
Don't do it again
Come on now, it was funny
It was funny boss
Just use the cloth from his balls
It'll work
You can tie it up with the cloth
I like
I like it
Hey, hey, you get you get candle play line is gets knife play
I got a little ball torture come on now
Yeah, you got no balls left
Hey, hey
Just one candle
It was one, it was one little rope
One little street
I'm gonna go look
No, I'm going I'm going god damn
Sassy pants
I'm gonna go get some rope
All right, Warro is awake now
So he just stops screaming for a second
He comes down
How long do you think you can keep this up
What
Do you have kids
We'll just have to do with anything
Well, I just want to know before
Well, because you might not be able to have them anymore so
That's funny to you
See
This game that we've been playing
Of course it's fun
But it's only fun
It could be even more fun
When we both have fun
I'm gonna go you've fun
And he's gonna try to slash again
Gonna make a deck safe
All right, we'll take half of that
What is this other damage that I'm rolling for?
Let me check what is this
It
It, there was some other damage
I don't know what it is
48 slashing
I don't know what the fuck this is
Okay, 48 slashing
What was the first one? 24
You take half of that
We're just slashing
That's 12
Two
We're just serving you
One tea ghost that kicked me
Like
Oh, like
I'm dodging the silky graze
And I'm just gonna walk up to him
Um
Back to date my arms of ass or so
Mm-hmm
Okay
Are you sure about that
See
I can designate when to have the like force explosion happen
Okay, okay, okay, just making sure
Okay, yeah, okay
Okay
And essentially
They're going to be acting
I'm aiming for
His balls
Okay
Can I get advantage since he's playing chrome?
Uh, bro, just do a crit man. I don't I think balls are like
Just do a crit for all
Okay
All right
Is that normal or is it double?
That was a crit
Does it double?
Oh, it's for force
Yeah
But it says 2d8 plus 5 plus 10 plus 1d8
That's how it always is
Because
Just as a reference
I don't know who it is
But
If I do a regular one
Um
No, the damage will
The damage will always like
Oh
You did roll to
Okay, you did roll to
Two twos, okay
Okay, 28
Yeah, and 19
All right, do you want to keep going?
You know what? Yeah
Okay
Does he like it
I don't think he likes it
Big question, do I come back with the rope yet?
Yes
You will just after this
I'm seeing Baptiste take all this man's balls with some ghostly horns
Yes, yes, you do
All right, is that it or do you want to keep going?
Oh, he's still awake
He isn't going to be knocked out, but I want to know when Baptiste is going to stop
When he comes of course
Okay
For our sport
No, that one
As soon as you like three of the hits
Like
Like it has balls
He does take all of that damage, but with the third
With the fourth one the chair just flops over as he like knocks out
I'm going to walk in here and him thud down and be like
Jesus boss, what the fuck were you doing to him?
He is starting to bleed a lot from his balls by the way
So
Come on, come on, your line is in here
Just have them give them a second me real quick
Make sure you can never have kids
Like I'm clean because I'm
Look at me, I ain't got fur
I ain't an animal
I'm just going to get the same to tiger
Just give me the rope
Fine, you're no fun
Why are you so serious?
Do I have like a
If I were to hang him from the ceiling do I have some things where I can like
Oist his arms up to like
I'm probably some like pipe that's going to be
Some like pipe that's going through the ship somewhere
You all got it?
Steel beam
Do that with his arms
And then have his legs like
Broke down to the ground
Okay
They're just basically extending him both ways
Yes
Alright, cool
Anything else
Was that it for now?
You should the door, you get outside
Roma, what are you doing?
Well obviously boss man's kicking me out of his room
So I'm going to go
I'm going to go figure out where line this is
Oh god
I'm going to demand to fix me
I'm chilly
Alright
Yeah
Not used to this
Alright, while that is happening, mouth is you're flying over
And the ocean bit
And you kind of see him kind of
She was acting a bit
Unoffraid of this but as soon as you start to fly higher and higher
She is kind of clinging on to you a bit too hard
She looks around and she goes
Okay, so usually
Can you hand me the map?
Yeah
She looks over and she goes usually the
Whatever the royal movement
The real
Open route to between islands is this one
They try to keep it open and like kind of guarded
But there's doesn't seem to be any
Guarding marine warships around
Probably because they're after you chasing you
So this she like kind of
Points it to like a big like channel
Of water flowing
And she points it to there and she goes
Well that is the channel that usually
The nobles take to get from island to island
So maybe you guys can ambush them here
It's still what pretty early in the day so they might not
Have gotten there if they have gotten there we're
F*cked already so let's just wait it out
All right then to get back
Going back down
Okay, all right so I'm gonna say all of this happens
While you were flying there and flying back over
What the f*ck is this wrong?
What the f*ck is this?
So you come back down
Baptiste you would be able to spot them coming down
You put her down as she like kind of
Lans on her feet which she wenses a bit
Because of the pain on one of her legs
As she like stumbles her way toward
Baptiste and she goes well
There she planned genius and don't bother me until you need me again of course
She just goes down without really explaining anything
You came out to help
Yeah whatever
It's only because you were the being dumb
That's why I can take you
Planning to kill yourself anyway
I'll be heading out now
Also did you guys manage to find my book
Or probably not right?
The book that make magic things happen
What was someone that went to find you?
Okay
So that's a no
Hey dog I didn't find her
That was a 100% Linus
And I was only told to find her
Not anything about a damn book
If you would have said find me a book
And then we're almost going to look for like a book around him
And just grab it and f*ck it throw it
There you go
Well I
Okay, well I can kick us
That's it for that
She's gonna just head into her room and just close it
I don't know who ever's room it was
Okay well it's gone
You're all hungry
Well what did you want to talk about?
Something
You came up to me
I'm sorry talking to you about it
You don't fix me
Doc I'm cold I feel exposed
I don't like this feeling
That's you
See what I mean
I mean you can always use your devil through it
And the fur will go back
Right
No no
You listen to your mother f*cker
You make me my wolf again
Or so help me God
I'm gonna drink something else
Roma
You drank it yourself
All right
You didn't tell me no
You didn't tell me to stop
You drank it in two seconds
That green one looks familiar
That green one
Mine is off
Yeah
Go drink it then
I
I'm gonna put it in my pocket
I'm gonna make it
Look like I drink it
Can you do
Slide of hand
Help
No it's gonna be trash
You have to let's do it's not bad
Passive receptions everyone
What is it
That's good
It should show up
You have 16
Okay
Everyone sees it
Oh my God
Do you drink that
I don't know what there's about to happen
Oh
He kind of rolls his eyes
And
Walks off
You talked all that
You can't even drink it
Drink something and it turn me into this
This
I'm gonna take it from his pocket
And shut it down his throat
All right that's gonna be
Struggled so just just make a
Straight strength check both of you
Are you letting it happen
Are you letting it happen Roma
Or are you
Okay, okay
He wouldn't
All right you try to try to grab
Like the while
Baptiste but he just snaps at you
And just pushes you away
Don't make some food God damn it
You know
As I'm walking away can I pop the
Vile and just
Gave a little finger to see what would happen
You want to dab like
A little finger and lick it
Yeah a little finger and just lick it
All right
Okay, I'm gonna make a wisdom save please
You said save
Oh
As soon as you like
Take like a little
Dab of it you
Kind of feel like
Goosebumps in your body for a bit but nothing really happens
Do I feel like any animalistic urge
Or just goose bumps
Can you make an inside checks
On yourself yes
Insights
Oh this will be horrible
You did you do have like this sense of
Kind of like
A bad omen that that kind of sense like something what bad was about to happen
But that's about it
You get just this like God feeling
I'm gonna hold on to this one
Okay
All right okay he's dying
He's dying guys
All right
I got a hold on to that one
Well who's gonna explain the plan
And someone relay the plan actually
Glad to go back to that fort
Not port is just like a big channel
Driving toward the place yeah essentially
It's pretty far away from the island still but yeah
Question
Yes
Do we have any like
Do we still have that motorized ship that they picked us up on
Who
Not the motorized it was like a hand roll ship but you would be able to like board it somewhere like alongside your ship
Okay let me roll if
It got destroyed in the fight or not
One is destroyed too is not okay it's just right
Sorry
So we don't have any other side ship
No no no
It's a pretty small boat yeah
You don't really have them by default you have to get them
Just tell us who we can use romance like uh so he has a different look
Oh yeah that is true that is true
Like you can infiltrate
The Roma would never come up with this plan
That's what I'm still
Roma wouldn't
You know we got other people can yeah
And Baptiste who are tacticians
Yeah
Of course our great tactician of course Baptiste
Alright uh let's uh let's uh let's uh plan
So you're gonna follow Zim's plan or do you have anything else
Well it's the best option we have for now
All right
All right so someone's gonna tell Kay to turn the ship
Toward that
And he's going to go do that
All right
Uh as he turns around the ship
You can like clearly hear like the ship is struggling to even move
Um yeah and you start going in that direction
You start going in that direction
Um a couple hours pass and you kind of lay your anchor
And near that area drop your like uh
Mass and everything so you can stay stationary for a while
While you wait
Uh for another ship to come in
From a safe distance so no one really immediate spots your ship
Um
All right so
So
Let's see anyone I'm gonna take a short rest
After the fucking small scuffle
All right
Oh yeah you too
Yeah
Everyone got up to some bullshit
I was just flying Zim in the air
Yeah
Just the courier pigeon I guess
I guess
Three HP that's crazy
All right
Spurt uses backup
It dies back up
All right
All right then
Are you ready?
Yep
All right now we'll continue next session
Oh
You somehow survived
Poor riff he's gonna die
The riff
Yeah
Yeah you were not listening
I wasn't
Uh okay so the initial call
Yeah it's them attacking
Yeah
Like there's a different
There's a different dude trying to take charge
No uh so the guy that
Baptiste talked to at the start of the session
Right
He was the one guy
Comrade O'Bregs that is going to
Desibella
To confirm like
If everything's going according to plan
He that Desibella is going to join
The World Kingdom
But he also found out that you guys have
Voro and you guys have connection to
Riff and there's supposed to be a
Meeting and
You threatened him on the call
What he said no
And
Well so he dies
I'm gonna roll for it
But there's a high chance
You're gonna die
Okay well technically
We've got to confirm that we knew them
You them?
Well
Yeah I mean so far I told them
Right
Who?
Ladies so far anthem
The one that escaped
The one that Roma
Well yeah but she
Okay wait but still there are witnesses
There are more people that know this
I also kind of did give that
Or flag
Yeah and like
You did like hold a big
Public
What do you call it?
Baby back fight
Yeah
Oh no we had a giant swarray
Afterwards
Yeah that too
Let me and Bob
What you got high with some Panthers
Yeah
Like I mean there's a way to do this
Coherkley you did not do it coherkley
Just so you know
Anyway it's in the paper so it's true
He could have
Exactly
Yeah exactly
Sorry what
He's still with a
Hardly
Did it to make an example
I mean yeah it could have but
You know actions have consequences and consequences have to show
The same goes for the Marines
Yeah
Yeah yeah I get it
Just want to say
I love us back together
Yeah
Roma still needs to find his warehouse
Or Linus almost promised like a wizard
You know
That's what I'm saying like I can't wait
Yeah you need to find it
You can leave me alone
Yeah
What you mean
Roma walked in
And saw candle wax on a borrow
And line the standing next to him
You said you were just in the room
He's trying to put you together
Yeah
We're tag team in this dude with candle wax
And it was dimly lit
You had never come to my room this much
Yeah
Honestly
Because I never thought you were into this
I'm saying
I love that
Malfus has no idea what has been happening
Yeah
I don't think I want to know
I think you're safe
I'm like oh dude like oh my god
Like
I got a stuck up captain
And then I find out that you went to some freaky shit like this
And when you're Roma definitely coming to your room
He's definitely like oh ship captains into this
So are there like any plans that we're going to tell Mira about the
Captain on board or no
Mira this for the house
Okay
Alright
Let's omit that information
We're not technically lying are we
Yeah
No
You were busy
And Mira was on vacation
Yeah
It's been fucking the week
But she's still on vacation
Yeah
True
That's just going to get him in trouble
Yeah
Well another the newspaper is going to come in like maybe four or five days from now
So you have time
We have time to get another bite
Yeah
To get ahead of it
You know
The judge is going to say hey you don't pay
He told us to do this
Yeah
It was his idea
All the long
The plan is
He gets rolled in back
So we need to make
But hey we have so many
Yeah
Let's go
You're like oh we had a captain but let him go for droven
Also
We castrated that captain so he can know
Let's go
We still had the captain
We're just going to take the handsome
Two
We also started
We also started a revolt on an island a resistance
That we just let them
Yeah you should probably
You should probably
Would have heard about that
I can't wait
Before we left
We might talk to Rick about them choosing what they wanted to do next
Yeah
Whether that be
We all knew the risks
It just don't happen
The circumstances
For this
Yeah
Well you don't know what his decision was at the end of the day
And you don't know
If he survives or not
So we'll find out next time
We'll have another prison break
If he gets captured
He's not going to get captured
I'm done with prison breaks
This is the last one
What do you mean
You want to do the same thing over and over?
That's not fun
I'm already doing it twice
You know
You're just going to kill everyone
You can do a slave option
You know
If it's
If it's like a recording thing
Like when they get captured
And they get broken out
Then of course people are going to make different decisions this time
Yeah
Just put them up for option
And with layoffs
And we'll go people
Yeah
You got to understand
It can be too nice
I have to have some consequences
Everyone's alive
Yeah
But you fucking exploded the canon that the acid was being loaded
Man what the fuck do you want
What the fuck do you talk to your team?
Yeah
I was just like yeah
Let's not let them use it all the time
So
Yeah
I will see you guys later
Okay
See you next week
I'm so glad we're back
I'm just still keeping saying
Do we
Do we know if Bob is going to
Show up next week or not
He hasn't said
Last time he said it was like
For a
A couple of weeks so it's going to be
The same like next week I guess
He just said he's going to have to leave
Keep people early
Okay, okay, okay, that's fine. That's fine. That's fine.
So let's see how we can do the action heavy stuff
In the beginning and then we'll do that
Yeah, right
We get into our fun sex
Yeah
I like it
Yeah, it's nice
All right then, I'm going to check the ship repair costs
First sec
I think we should go now
No, we're here. We're just getting the upgrades
Okay, I don't I don't think that's how that works
Well, I think we can do that
I won't not because I still have
300,000 bellies if it's less than that I'll just pay for it
I don't
Tell the ship to repair it so
We know it's sent to it
Ship six fences for you
It's above half
You know, we're just repaired the ship for each creature
Spends blah blah blah
Also restored the ship but equal amount of successful checks if the ship is been bought to
Okay, she's going to attempt temporary back
The leakage blah blah blah
Okay, you haven't sunk yet, so that's good but you are kind of stuck at the HP you have right now
Yeah
What about it? It's fine. We live
Can I hire somebody from that island to repair it? Like, I think I have a thousand
How much would it be? I just want to know
It's not it's not let me check
Um
From a known island for you to help us
But they would help Roma because he doesn't look the same
Yeah, but it's not going to help
It's not really help they're going to ask money and it's not going to be easy
I give them money if it's 300,000 I got 300,000 bellies
It's not there. It's going to be in millions and the way it is is going to be millions
They'll come to the ship to fix it and then they'll recognize it
Do you have the flag? Do you want to take down the flag?
Huh?
Nobody actually ever saw the ship except for that one house and you killed the dude from that one house
No, I did it
What one house? No, you know he didn't yeah
I thought he did
I was evaded
The station came up but I decided to just step on the gas instead
Yeah, uh, did you did you have like a whole reinforcement or something?
Reinforce whole yeah, you did reinforce kill
Oh, yeah, yeah reinforce kill would include yeah, repairment
Okay, so the 10 million for reinforce kill would go to the repair as well
That's fine because it increases the max hit points
Uh, so whatever your current is will just max it out to that right
No, your half is not gonna max it out
Huh, well
Let's see
Okay, just an out or a current one by the way
I'll talk to you guys next week
Yeah, yeah, talk to you later, man
But
So right now you are at
I fucking forgot to save it
I'll assume it's gonna be 300 okay half
Uh, and then if you add 100 so that's gonna be 400
But it's not gonna go to the max 600 unless you repair it I think
I can't because you can leave out the next new bedroom then we have two new bedrooms or a new cat or instead of a cannon
All right, all right, we'll figure it out when it comes to it, it's fine
All right, next we are taking hostages
Nice
I'll plan accordingly